iceland is a stunning volcanic melting
pot
on the edge of the arctic circle
it has some of the most extraordinary
beautiful landscapes known to man
and a unique food world to match
this place is home to rotten shark whale
meat and something i've always wanted to
try puffing
here they have a puffin feast on the
menu i'm intrigued to see what it
delivers in terms of texture and flavor
and more importantly i'm dying to find
out what it actually tastes like
i'm sampling a starter of fresh salad
with smoked puffing thank you and
where's the puffin dunny it's all over
here oh the dark bits see it's hiding in
the bushes again yes it is see where is
it thank you
never tasted anything like it before
i actually quite like it it's very
creamy slightly gamey a little bit salty
but quite intriguing because it's very
smooth on the palette
and obviously a [ __ ] nightmare to
catch because there's hardly any on my
[ __ ] plate
puffin is such an amazing new ingredient
i'm keen to grill the local chefs about
it
fascinating for me my first time eating
puffin very dark yeah very dark rich
bird yeah and it smells a little bit
like liver it's quite quite quite dark
like a lamborgh dark beet a little bit
like game like you said yeah and yeah it
really rich flavor i enjoyed it i'm
intrigued by it thank you
having tasted puffing for the first time
i want to find out where they come from
and learn the age-old way of hunting
them
so i'm moving further south
i've seen some airports in my time but
this is taking the piss
[Applause]
i'm heading to the westmon islands 10
miles off iceland's south coast
there are more atlantic puffins on these
remote islands than anywhere else in the
world
[Music]
the birds are a traditional food 100
centuries by locals like oliver tier
ollie
hi there hi there good to see you
welcome to westmill islands thank you
now
you look like a little puffy bulky
sturdy yeah there you go full of stamina
yeah can you fly not really but uh i'm
always hoping to so you need a lot of
puffins in the uk yeah everyone right
now will be thinking oh my god they're
cute they're beautiful they're lovely
beaks we've got them as teddy bears for
the kids why in the hell are you eating
them well to begin with there are a lot
of them around here there are four or
five million perfect so they're in
abundance the traditional food in
western islands are the puffins
especially smoked puffins so it goes
back centuries ago in terms of a staple
food supply that the island survived on
yeah yeah and uh
just tastes very good
the method oliver uses to catch them is
hundreds of years old
what is that thing it's called hour how
howard power yeah well it's close enough
okay let's just call it a pole vault
with a net on the end okay you can call
it whatever you like i called howard
there are no puffings on this open part
of the island so it's perfect for
practicing sky fishing i would wait for
the puffin flying this way slowly after
they and
turn and then they will fly into the net
take the puffing out
and break the net have a look the bird
is flying that direction follow follow
follow following
back why don't we just get a gun and
shoot them it's just more of a sport
yeah but i shoot them you catch them in
the air yeah as they fall at this car
the official hunting season doesn't
start until tomorrow which gives me
plenty of time to perfect my swing got
him yeah okay
i've got it
and cook another part of my puffing menu
a traditional icelandic bread
right i'm gonna make a really nice
rustic bread to go with the puffins for
tomorrow i'm adding yeast to rye flour
wholemeal flour salt and sugar
a little well in the center add the milk
in three stages
knead the dough until firm
and that's what we're looking for that
really nice smooth
beautiful rustic dough
into the tin i'm finishing the bread
with blowderg a traditional icelandic
flour
when you rub them together it releases
amazing oil it's a sort of cross between
lavender
and rosemary as that cooks it's gonna
perfume the bread
smells amazing
lid on now i'm gonna bake that bread in
the biggest oven i've ever seen in my
entire [ __ ] life
this is mount elfell a volcano that
erupted and changed the face of the
islands just 35 years ago
with the crater still hot enough to bake
a loaf
so this is the oven and the deeper you
go yep the hotter it is yes
honestly when that is absolutely
incredible
ah the heat yeah how hot that
is extraordinary
how long in the other two hours
yeah only the vikings were thinking
about digging deep under a volcanic rock
hard work being a baker yeah but i mean
how do i put the work in especially not
paying for the gas
the bread will bake overnight and
tomorrow the official puffing hunting
season on the westman islands will begin
it's the first day of the season and to
catch them we're heading even further
afield to one of ollie's best hunting
spots
so what are we going to hunt the puffins
uh it's on the other side of the island
yeah in the middle no not in the middle
on the edge on the edge yeah
what do you mean
like that
[ __ ]
olly you're
mad this is eck liver a one of the
westman's 14 uninhabited islands
it was difficult to access from the
water and having clambered to the top
for an hour i couldn't quite believe
where i ended up
[Music]
we're perched on the edge of a cliff
with an 80 meter drop into the north
atlantic ocean
i'm [ __ ] myself
relax be part of the nature
the puffins circle the edge catching the
wind and it didn't take long for ollie
to show me exactly how it's done
yep
yeah
ah that was quick yep
you hold the leg legs hold it lower
under the wings yes under the wings
the first one of the season is released
ready beautiful you're one lucky little
[ __ ]
my [ __ ] nose it lags you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] slice my nose
you little bastard ready yeah and go
that's the last time i'm kissing a
[ __ ] puffin
i start [ __ ] around we're on the side
of a cliff
huh
at 250 feet
this wasn't going to be easy very close
very close
i'm just worried about standing up on
the side of this
well you shouldn't worry too much no
forget that together
ollie makes sky fishing look easy but i
spent three hours on the cliff without
catching a thing
there's no way on earth i can go home
with a big [ __ ] cut on my nose and no
puffins trust me it's a lot more
difficult than i thought it would be
moving to the other side of the island
we were hoping our luck might change
oh yo
nope oh
okay
you're right you are
i was not letting that one go okay no
chance
jesus christ almighty huh
it had taken five hours but i finally
got the hang of it jesus fantastic
that was high that one
that's good very good puffing number two
we could have gone on catching for hours
but i only needed a couple of puffins to
cook with so i decided to set my third
one free
i'm gonna let this one go
you know
first day of the season
[Applause]
you got two i got two that's a good
number
let's go
back on the main island ollie showed me
the best way to de-breast the birds just
break
snap and break yep right and then do it
like this okay it's ready to do that's
incredible yeah and here you have the
heart the heart yeah yeah you want one
would you eat that yeah
iceland's very own hannibal lecter
then it was my turn
oh you have a heart as well ollie come
on come on don't be a chicken it's a
puffin
you're bitten by one and then you can
eat it it doesn't taste bad
oh [ __ ]
i can't believe it just made me that
hard right hannibal let me show you how
to cook them [ __ ] properly you stay
here yeah i look forward to this
unbelievable
the volcanic bread i made yesterday
turned out to be a big hit with the
locals because overnight
it got nicked but it was the puffing i
was here for and i couldn't wait to cook
with it
marinated puffing breast in brenovin
take the breast off the bone
[Music]
just a tad larger than a pigeon breast
but a hundred times tastier i'm making a
marinade for the puffing with crushed
juniper berries salt pepper and olive
oil two thirds olive oil and one third
brennevin brenevin's a local liqueur
like a schnapps
lovely
and then puffing straight into the
marinade
whilst the puffing marinades i'm making
a salad with skir an icelandic yogurt
cucumber garlic and mint
the nice thing about this cucumber salad
it cools down the richness of the
puffing
just slice through the breast
get your rosemary twig
push it through
and the nice thing about that as it
cooks it perfumes inside that puffing
breast it's a very lean bird so i don't
want this thing to dry out for the
barbecue cherry tomatoes on the vine
drenched with olive oil and balsamic
vinegar
and now for the puffing straight on the
barbecue
[Music]
lovely literally one minute each side
and once i barbecued them they're going
back in the marinade nice
bread
now unfortunately our bread got knicked
last night so this is what ollie cooked
at his house
the tomatoes just sat on the bread ski
cucumber salad
and then this a puffin breast just pull
out the rosemary
wow that is delicious and that
is our perfect puffing fit
for any [ __ ] viking
ollie's invited his sons down to see if
my puffin passes the test i'm dying to
see what you think in terms of flavor
have you ever eaten it that rare no this
tastes much better than i ever expected
really yeah good man for me the flavour
of puffing is unique i love it and
here's the good news yeah now i've got
my licence yeah i'm coming back you've
got your laser
yes then we have a real competition one
more
take careful aim
when you're ready
what was the fact